a woman who was born in the US and left
the country to fight for Isis is tonight
begging to come back home
Cortana Benjamin Hall recently spoke
with Hoda Mathon Oh who is now in a
refugee camp in northern Syria in the
dying days of the Caliphate thousands of
Isis families fled into the Syrian
desert
trying to escape among them Howe DeMuth
Anna the woman born in America who
joined Isis and now regrets it
but the US says Mehsana is not and has
never been a US citizen because her
father was a yemeni diplomat at the time
of her birth
Malala lived in Hoover Alabama and
claims she was radicalized online in
2014 Isis was ascendant committing
horrible atrocities and 19 year old
Donna left the u.s. to join them
[Music]
you've got to do better than that you've
got to got to explain this decision but
she couldn't accept no comment and
always that laughter and it's an aisle
she hated America
she married three Isis fighters had a
child and became a mouthpiece for the
terror group
go on drive-bys and spill all their
blood she tweeted or rent a big truck
and drive all over them kill them
she claims Isis took over her Twitter
account and that now with therapy she
could become a model citizen
Madonna denies that she only fled the
Caliphate because it fell but her tweets
and the timeline suggest otherwise and
in the eyes of the State Department
she's nothing more than a terrorist
Brett Benjamin thank you